Hello and welcome.
I'm Nancy Salzman.
I'm the president
of NXIVM Corporation,
and executive success programs.
What would happen if each
of my secrets came out?
REPORTER: Arrested today,
Nancy Salzman
as well as her daughter,
Lauren Salzman.
NANCY SALZMAN:
The upside of letting go
of your secrets
is that you will have
a lot more freedom.
REPORTER:
REPORTER 2: Lauren Salzman
now pleading guilty.
REPORTER 3: Alison Mack cracks.
SALZMAN: The downside
of your secrets coming out
is punishment.
My whole company was destroyed,
and my whole life fell apart.
REPORTER 4:
The explosive trial of NXIVM
sex cult leader Keith Raniere.
SPEAKER: Brainwashing,
sex abuse, and even branding.
It was really the psychological
torture of women for decades.
SPEAKER 2: If he gets off, then
it's back to full-blown
battle stations,
and then, they're coming
after us.
SPEAKER 3:
Keith, I can rationalize
that he's crazy, but Nancy...
she puzzles me more than Keith.
Seventeen thousand people
got good results.
Where are they?
People think, "Anyone who's
still around are just
brainwashed bitches of Keith."
How insulting.
How could I have allowed myself
to be there?
These are adult women
making decisions. Back off.
She's young, and she's alone.
And he wants her
to be his slave.
SPEAKER 4:
What the...
SALZMAN: Going into this,
I thought Keith was innocent.
I was wrong.
SPEAKER 5: I wonder
if she's really waking up
or just trying to save herself.